Yeah, it was fucking raining out.
This is one thing I've learned that when you go to a football game and you're
dealing with the elements,
this is the more of a douchebag you look like the warmer you're going to be.
All right. I saw the rain and I said fuck this.
And we went right to deck sporting good and I'm like, I'm buying that fucking,
I'm going to buy a rain coat with the matching rain coat slacks.
I don't give a fuck.
I bought a pair of a wool socks and I was good to go.
So I'm with Versie and you know they only had like two raincoats left and they
were the exact same color.
This fucking grape slush puppy purple.
So we both have matching extra large fucking,
we got the jackets and the pants like we're working at a fucking airport and
what green we're bringing in the fucking soul plane. Right.
That was a purple airplane. Right. That's what we look like.
So we show up to the game, right.
Neither one of us is comfortable because neither one of us is a jets or a bills
fan. So we're in enemy territory and it's fucking drizzling and out.
It's fucking cold. So I proceed to put on this Barney the dinosaur outfit,
right? And right off the bat, Versie starts pumping out outgoing man.
I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna wear that. I'm just gonna wear the top.
I'm just gonna wear the top, trying to act like it's not raining out that bed.
The reality is,
is he didn't want to go through the hazing that he would have to,
if the two of us walked in with our purple on
Purple Fucking Rain Coats Times two, we would have got a ton of shit.
And I was prepared to take it. I had an,
I had a whole fucking silly walk I was going to be doing. I don't give a fuck.
So he punked out. So, uh, we ended up walking in and put my head's cold, right?
All I have is a baseball cap on. So I'm like, fuck, I gotta buy a head.
Can I buy a bill's who gives a fuck there? And last pace mail by a bill's hat.
And then I saw this, this one with a Patriot logo on it. I said, fuck it.
I'll get that. Once I put that one on, I'm nice and warm. We go to, we'll call,
we pick up our tickets.
We go into that high school football stadium that they have out there that I
actually love. It looks like an old school football stadium.
You know what I like about that football stadium that's about the size of a
football stadium that holds real fans. You know what I mean? All these,
these new ones that hold like 100,000 fucking pets,
all the bandwagon shit heads.
You know when you're all in for the real fucking fans show up all and three,
right? So we walk into the Goddamn stadium with love and life, right?
I'm already laughing at Versie cause I know damn well what's going to happen?
He's going to walk out there.
There's going to be some shitty little plastic seat that's going to be covered
in fucking water and the only way he's going to be able to absorb it is through
his God damn jeans and his fucking bbds.
And then he's going to be sitting there with a wrinkled up,
nuts sack that's going to be getting hypothermia by second quarter.
Why do I know this? I've been there.
So we've got a couple of bears.
We get this fucking beef on a stick or whatever the fuck they call it.
We're good to go. We go in there, sit down,
he sits basically down in a fucking puddle. He tried to stick a newspaper down,
which is a very absorbent and a, I dunno.
We sat there and I had hope for about eight seconds in that game and the jets
came down and just fucking Jew. They just kicked the shit out of him.
Christ. They kicked a shit out of 'em and uh,
hey, it was just over. So we, so immediately,
our solution is just to start drinking the way we drank at the masters.
We're like, fuck it. Let's, let's, let's get going here, right?
So we'll make a trip after trip and all of a sudden I gotta take a Piss, right?
So I go and I'm standing in line and all of a sudden this,
this fucking six foot five goofy looking jackass,
one of those guys who's like six foot five but you still think he can take them
cause he's just covered in baby fat. You know,
he's got a couple of whiskers on his chin and his cheeks are rosier than St Nick
, right? And he's got this Jersey on and this big stupid,
I'm a buffalo bills fan with the horns on it and stuff. You know,
he's the Wacky Guy, so I'm not even thinking shit. Right.
This is bill's jets. I don't have a dog in this fight. I'm not talking any shit.
I'm fine.
I forgot I was wearing my patriots hat and all of a sudden this big goofy
jackass starts going, wait, wait, what's what? Yeah. Will Your patriots fit?
Do you like the rats? We got to [inaudible] the rats.
He likes the fucking rats and the shit. Right? And I'm like, yeah, you know,
whatever. He starts giving me shit. I start giving him shit back.
And then the weirdest fucking thing happened. I,
by the time I get in to the actual men's room,
I've talked,
I've given these people so much fucking shit that actually there's bills and
jets fans at a bill's and jets game. They're playing each other. They stop,
stop giving each other shit,
and they teamed up together and started giving me shit.
Right? And then I just said, I don't know what I was thinking.
I felt like I was on stage cause it was like a crowd. I wasn't thinking like,
Hey, you know what, Bill,
you really haven't had a fight outside of your family since maybe playing so
fucking street hockey in the sixth grade. I didn't give a fuck.
I'm going to goddamn bathroom waiting to take a piss in a goddamn trough by the
way. And a,
and then they just started giving up fucking just one dude such go on.
Tom Brady Sucks Dick.
He shocks Dick and he's like miming it like ridiculously well. So I'm like,
yeah, you know buddy, you do that real wealth.
Because I learned it by watching Tom Brady. I'm like, Oh yeah,
did you rent that portal? You fucking fag gets a little uglier,
gets a little uglier than this other dude. What the fuck do you do it?
I came up with the hell he was saying to me and I said, look, I'm sorry.
You guys have never won a super bowl. You know?
Then the jets fan pipes in. I go,
do you realize the last time you guys won a super bowl,
Charlie Chaplin was still alive? Do you understand that?
Do you know what cars look like the last time you won? You fucking morons.
And then, uh, then this other guy goes, the, we've won three super bowls.
I'm sorry. Right? And then the guy goes, well, you didn't play in the games.
I go, neither did yo.
Then he's just standing there with his dumb look on his face. Like, oh,
that's where I keep staring for with, you've got nothing
forgetting that I don't know how to fight.
So all of a sudden it's my turn to Piss. I take my dick out, I'm ready to Piss.
And one of these fucking pussies pushed me in the back hoping that I was pissing
at the time. Fortunately, I wasn't. So I turn around,
I put my dick away cause I'm a gentleman. I said, well gee,
I goes and how you guys do it out here? Really? I go,
which one do you guys push me? Like I'm gonna fall like I'm fucking Jackie Chan.
And for some reason none of them said anything.
I don't know if it was my purple on purple rain coat or the look of fire in my
eye,
but I'm a fucking 42 year old balding redhead talking shit in there and none of
them said anything. So now it's kind of funny to me.
I felt like I was in like the world series of poker and I went all in and I
didn't have a hand whatsoever. So I don't know who the fuck pushed me.
But that's what I mean. Come on. Bitchy is move with the fucking week.
How do you do that? How do you do that? How do you,
how do you push another man when he's got his Goddamn Dick out trying to piss
into a fucking trough? I mean, how do you get lower than that?
Do you guys have any ideas? How do you get lower than that?
So then after none of them said anything, I go back and I started taking a piss.
And then that other dude who was miming somebody sucking a dick unbelievably
well right next to me.
We one of those stupid hats that has the toggles on the side and he's still
trying to give me shit and I'm going to to go fuck yourself.
And then he just starts screaming over and over again.
Are you looking at my Dick? Are you looking at my deck?
Like maniacally, like five times.
I just sort of stared at him like, why do you keep going this, this gay angle?
Like why is there always a, I dunno.
I think he was one of those guys. He was Kinda in the closet. And then, uh,
so he just goes to football games and he gets really drunk trying to just kill
the families. I think he liked me is what I'm saying.
So if he's listening to this, I'm sorry. Uh,
I'm spoken for you fucking pants. You fucking believe that.
First of all, what's wrong with me?
I really replayed all of that in my head cause once I got out of there I was
like, I really started thinking like, what?
What did you think you were going to do in there?
They're not Clint Eastwood yet saying things. Clint Eastwood would say, what?
What the fuck is wrong with you dude?
Like I don't know if I've said this before in a podcast,
a public bathroom is the worst fucking place to ever get into a fight.
There is nothing soft.
There's everything is porcelain pipes that concrete floor and then it has a mist
of piss and shit. It's just a fucking, it's the worst.
It's the worst place ever. You know,
not to mention it usually starts evidently when one person as begun,
the pissing process.
Okay.
So, uh, you know, older, little bit wiser.
So then I'm standing in line to go get some more alcohol cause God knows that's
what you need after an incident like that.
And I was just kinda just sitting there thinking like, all right,
now how should I have played that?
It w it should have ended when the dude with the water buffalo hat started
giving me shit. What I should should've done was roll with it.
I should you like the Patriots. I should have been like, Yay. You know,
you guys scored 30 on this last week, man. You guys look great man.
Now I bet the jets, I mean, I bet against the jets.
I hope you guys should have just ended it with that and did it. I've,
I sh I should, uh, I should have extended in all of branch.
That's what I should have done in the future.
That's what the fuck I'm gonna do because, uh,
that was a, a, that was a potentially ugly situation. But fortunately,
um, I think the people who were doing it, you know,
had jobs and no one wanted to get sued and no one was willing to take it to that
level. Uh, and when I say fortunately,
I mean for me and my face.
Okay.
Oh,
do you know how bad that would have been to get stomped in that fucking purple
on purple rain coat lay in there with my dirty fucking patriots hat
and my team wasn't even playing. I would have lost the lawsuit.
They would have been like, let me get this straight. You're a patriots fan.
You are a patriots hat to a bill's jets game and you somehow managed to get the
shit kicked out of you. What the fuck did you say? You know,
that's one of the great things about being a guy is you actually have to take
responsibility for your, for your actions. See, you won't be like,
there's no excuse. There's no reason. I don't care what happened. You know,
and he had a girl, which is true. You don't need a fucking girl.
But there no learning in that. There's no lesson. You know?
Even my best friends would have been like, yeah,
those guys are fucking assholes in the, but you know,
they would've been an awkward pause and it'd be like, dude, what the fuck?
He talking shit for by yourself at a game when your team isn't even fucking
playing, what's wrong with you? You're 42 years old, get your shit together.
And they would have been right.